TO MAKE AN IMPACT, A LOT OF THE
12 POINTS IN THE SECOND HALF
WHEN THE THUNDER NEEDED IT.
HE HAD A LOT OF GREAT ENERGY
WHEN THE THUNDER WERE CHOPPING
DOWN THAT SACRAMENTO LEAD.
SO A SOLID PERFORMANCE BY THE
ROOKIE.
WITH 25.3 SECONDS LEFT HERE,
MICHAEL, IT IS SACRAMENTO'S TURN
TO POTENTIALLY DROP SOMETHING
OFF HERE OFFENSIVELY.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING FOR?
>> Michael: YOU KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO TRY TO GET THE BALL IN
THE HANDS OF BARNES OR HIELD.
EITHER ONE ARE GOOD AT MIDRANGE.
IF YOU ARE THE THUNDER, PLAY THE
CLOCK OUT, PLAY SOLID DEFENSE.
THE KINGS WILL RUN IT ALL THE
WAY DOWN AND SEE IF THEY CAN GET
THE LAST-SECOND SHOT.
>> Chris: IT IS DORT PICKING THE
POCKET OF FOX.
THREE ON THE TIMER.
DORT STEPS IN.
LAYS IT UP AND IN WITH 1.7!
WHAT A DEFENSIVE PLAY!
>> Michael: NOT ONLY DID HE MAKE
THE BIGGEST DEFENSIVE PLAY OF
THE GAME, HE WENT COAST-TO-COAST
AND FINISHED THROUGH THE
CONTACT.
MY GOODNESS.
WHAT A SERIES OF FORTUNATE
EVENTS FOR THE THUNDER ON THAT
PLAY.
FOX LOST THE BASKETBALL.
>> Chris: FLAT OUT HAD HIS
POCKET PICKED.
DRIVEN IT OFF THE LEG OF DORT,
AND DORT, NO HESITATION
WHATSOEVER, GOES RIGHT AT BUDDY
HIELD WITH THE SCOOP AND SCORE
FOR THE BIGGEST BUCKET OF THE
GAME.
>> Michael: HE DOES A GREAT JOB
OF JUST STAYING FOCUSED.
HE DIDN'T CELEBRATE WHEN HE
STOLE THAT BASKETBALL, WHICH
THERE'S A LOT OF ENERGY GOING
THROUGH YOUR BODY AT THAT POINT.
HE HAD THE PRESENCE OF MIND AND
THE FOCUS TO SAY, LOOK, WE NEED
TWO POINTS TO SURGE AHEAD HERE
AND PUT A LOT OF PRESSURE ON THE
KINGS WITH 1.7 SECONDS REMAINING
TO COME UP WITH A PLAY.
>> Chris: WELL, IT WAS THE
THUNDER'S BEST ON-BALL DEFENSIVE
PLAYER IN DORT, MAKING THE
GAME'S BIGGEST PLAY AS
SACRAMENTO WAS HOLDING OUT TO
TRY TO SETTLE FOR THE WIN OR
OVERTIME.
NOT ONLY CAUSING THE TURNOVER,
MICHAEL, BUT THEN TO GO RIGHT TO
THE RIM WITH FOUR SECONDS LEFT,
COVERING THE LENGTH OF THE
COURT.
>> Michael: THAT'S A GOOD POINT
YOU ARE MAKING.
A LOT OF TIMES YOU THINKING
ABOUT HOLDING THE BASKETBALL
BACK TO TRY TO MAKE A PLAY.
HE KNEW HE WAS OUT FRONT.
THE DEFENSE WAS BEHIND HIM, AND
HE JUST BEE LINED IT TO THE
BASKET.
>> Chris: WELL, SACRAMENTO IS
NOW OUT OF TIME-OUTS, BUT 1.7 TO
TRY TO GET OFF A SHOT.
WITH THE THUNDER UP BY TWO, IT
IS FOX FROM THE SIDELINE.
LOOKING TO GET IT INTO HIELD.
HIELD HAS THE THREE.
AND IT IS OFF TARGET AND OKC
SURVIVES WITH THE VICTORY!
>> Michael: YOU EVER FEEL LIKE
YOU WANT TO SAY TO YOURSELF, WE
GOT TO STOP MEETING LIKE THIS?
MY GOODNESS.
WHAT A WEEK OF GOOD, SOLID
DOWN-TO-THE-WIRE BASKETBALL IT
HAS BEEN AND THE THUNDER ARE NOT
DONE YET AS THEY COME FROM
BEHIND, DOWN BY AS MANY AS 18 IN
THE FIRST HALF, TO UPEND THE
KINGS BY A DEUCE.
>> Chris: HIELD CAUGHT THE PASS,
GOT A CLEAN LOOK, AND IT NEVER
HAD A CHANCE.
IT WAS TWO FEET SHORT, AND
SMILES AS LU DORT KISSES
SACRAMENTO GOOD NIGHT.
>> Michael: A WELL-EARNED
VICTORY AS WELL AS, YOU KNOW,
YOU TALK ABOUT GRITTY AND JUST
DOING THE DIRTY WORK OF THE
GAME, AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
IT BECOMES A LABOR OF LOVE IN
THE FOURTH QUARTER.
>> Chris: LET'S CHECK IN WITH
NICK WHO IS WITH LU.
>> Nick: LU, THE BIGGEST PLAY OF
THE NIGHT AND YOU GET THE JOB
DONE.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT FEELING?
>> I MEAN WE JUST HAD TO FINISH
THE GAME.
I KNOW -- I KNOW THEY HAD ONE
MORE POSSESSION LEFT.
I JUST HAD TO STEP UP AND GET A
STOP AND GO OUT STRONG.
>> Nick: ANOTHER COMEBACK NOW OF
16 OR MORE POINTS, THE FOURTH
ONE ALREADY THIS SEASON.
TELL ME ABOUT THE HEART OF THIS
GROUP.
>> WE JUST HAVE TO COMPETE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE COACH EMPHASIZED A LOT.
YOU KNOW, WE JUST LISTEN AN WE
KNOW WE CAN DO IT.
WE KNOW WE'RE ONE OF THE
YOUNGEST TEAMS BUT WE HAVE TO
COME OUT AND PLAY HARD.
>> Nick: SO MANY GUYS STEPPED
UP, TRE MANN, DARIUS BAZLEY,
JEREMIAH.
WHAT STOOD OUT TO YOU ABOUT THE
GROUP?
>> I MEAN IT IS THAT WE'RE A
GROUP.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE ALL GOING TO
COMPETE AND WE'RE ALL GOING TO
COME AND STEP UP, EVEN THOUGH
TRE WENT AND CAME BACK, IT IS A
LEARNING PROCESS AND WE'RE PROUD
OF HIM.
>> Nick: LU, I WAS TOLD IT IS
THE FIRST TIME YOUR MOM WAS ABLE
TO BE HERE IN OKLAHOMA CITY AND
WATCH YOU PLAY.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO YOU TO COME
AWAY WITH THE BIGGEST PLAY DOWN
THE STRETCH?
>> IT MEANS A LOT.
I MEAN THE FIRST TIME -- I MEAN
SHE HAS DONE A LOT FOR ME.
WITHOUT HER I WOULDN'T BE IN
THIS POSITION NOW.
AND I LOVE HER TO DEATH AND I'M
HAPPY SHE CAME TO SEE ME PLAYING
GOOD.
>> Nick: CONGRATS, LU.
ENJOY THIS ONE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Chris: HAS TO BE A LOT OF
EMOTION AND LU DORT PUTTING ON A
SHOW OF FINAL POSITION, SHOWING
WHY HE IS ONE OF THE BEST
ON-BALL DEFENSIVE PLAYERS IN THE
NBA AND THEN THE AWARENESS TO
CHARGE HIS WAY DOWN THE FLOOR
FOR THE GAME-WINNING DEUCE,
WHICH WAS JUST ENOUGH AS OKC
ONCE AGAIN WITH A STEEP HILL TO
CLIMB DID SO IN THE